[Music]
Lisa Marie Presley laid to rest the
Stars next to her son Benjamin Keough
who died in 2020 in the meditation
Garden at Graceland in Memphis Tennessee
anything happening with him I feel if
they're sick I get sick if there's
something happens to them I'm going
through it you know it's beautiful but
painful situation EC's learned
Benjamin's grave was slightly moved to
make room for her I don't know what to
do with myself I'm not if I'm not a mom
a public memorial service was held at
the Presley Family Estate on Sunday many
fans gathered to pay their respects
offering condolences and leaving gifts
the white bouquet of flowers were sent
from Oprah Winfrey E.T can confirm I'm
going to read something that
my granddaughter
wrote
for all of you
during the service Lisa Marie's mother
Priscilla paid tribute to her daughter
in 1968 she entered our world she then
grew a family of her own
then came her second child it was time
for a tragedy
she knew what was close to the end
survivors
guilt some would say but a broken heart
was the doing of her death
now she is home where she always
belonged but my heart is missing her
love also in attendance were her three
children Riley Keough and twins Harper
and Finley Lockwood I'm going to read
something Riley wrote a letter to my
mama
thank you for being my mother in this
life I am eternally grateful to have
spent 33 years with you
I'm certain I chose the best mother for
me in this world and I knew that as far
back as I can remember you
notable Stars at the memorial Austin
Butler and his girlfriend Kaia Gerber
set second row behind the family Billy
Corrigan of the Smashing Pumpkins took
the stage to perform to Sheila you
make me
[Music]
while Alanis Morissette delivered a
beautiful rendition of her song rest
ourselves
[Music]
Lisa is loved and missed by many and
will continue to be loved and missed by
all those whose lives she touched after
giving a touching speech Guns and Roses
Axl Rose performed the band's 1991 track
November Rain
do you need some time all along I stand
here with great honor because we called
each other so this is for
you with affection meanwhile Sarah
Ferguson reflected on her friendship
with Lisa Marie my late mother-in-law
used to say that nothing can be said can
begin to take away the anguish and the
pain of these moments
because grief is the price we pay for
love
and how right she was so for Riley for
Harper and Finley and for the entire
family
we March forward in support of you all
of us are with you